Il existe déjà beaucoup de livres et de
documentaires sur l’histoire du tatouage.
On y parle le plus souvent des Polynésiens
à qui on a emprunté le mot “tattoo”,
des marins et des taulards qui s’en servaient
comme symbole identitaire, mais très peu
des périodes anciennes. Ou alors pour évoquer
rapidement qu’Ötzi, la célèbre momie
des glaces néolithique, portrait quelques
traces d’encre. Et c’est normal, c’est
l’état de la documentation. Il y a beaucoup
de sources et de travaux ethnographiques pour
les périodes récentes qui détaillent les
significations rituelles des tatouages, mais
peu de contenu accessible et synthétisé
pour les périodes anciennes.
Quand on veut faire une archéologie du tatouage,
ce qu’on va faire ici, il faut se frotter
à des livres et des dizaines d’articles,
en anglais pour la plupart, qui détaillent
des analyses microchimiques ou des listes
d’objets, et parfois, au milieu de tout
ça, on trouve ce dont on a besoin. Alors,
ça prend du temps, mais vous allez voir,
ça permet de découvrir des choses vraiment
inattendues.
Bonjour à toutes et à tous, je suis vraiment
ravie de vous retrouver enfin en face caméra
(apparemment ça a manqué à certains). Grâce
au soutien du CNC, on va se retrouver très
régulièrement ici : vous aurez tous les
quinze jours une vidéo face caméra puis
un épisode de Mission Archéo, la nouvelle
série documentaire à ne surtout pas louper.
Autour de moi j’ai une équipe flambant
neuve pour vous en mettre plein la vue tout 2023.
La chaîne reprend GRAVE du service,
moi j’dis ça valait le coup d’attendre.
Les éléments archéologiques qui nous renseignent
sur le tatouage aux périodes anciennes sont
de trois types : l’iconographie, les outils
et les restes de peau tatouées. Même s’il
n’y a que les restes de peau qui donnent
une preuve définitive de tatouage, et on
va en parler longuement, il faut d’abord
faire un point sur les autres indices.
L’iconographie d’abord, les images. On
possède de nombreuses statuettes et figurines
humaines dont la peau est décorée, mais
il est difficile de différencier des tatouages
permanents, des peintures corporelles éphémères
ou même de simples motifs décoratifs inventés
par les sculpteurs. Les statuettes de la culture
de Halaf dans le nord de la Syrie qui datent
du VIe millénaire avant J.-C., les statuettes
Dogū de la période Jōmon au Japon ou même
les statuettes cycladiques de mer Egée ont
pu faire penser à des représentations de
tatouages ou de scarifications. Mais dans
la mesure où des symboles similaires apparaissent
sur des poteries ou des figurines animales,
cette interprétation est assez fragile.
Les outils maintenant. On possède plusieurs
kits d’outils préhistoriques qui pourraient
bien être destinés au tatouage. Dans la
grotte préhistorique du Mas d’Azil qui
se situe dans les Pyrénées, a été retrouvé
un ensemble d’outils interprétés comme
un nécessaire de tatouage, et ce, dans les
niveaux les plus anciens du site, aux alentours
de 16 000 avant J.-C. Malheureusement, la
publication détaillée, un hors-série des
Annales de Paléontologie qui date de 1960,
n’est disponible qu’à la Bibliothèque
du Musée de l’Homme à Paris, et on n’a
pas pu le consulter pour préparer cette vidéo.
Si jamais quelqu’un a envie de mettre ça
sur internet… surtout ne vous privez pas.
Le site du Mas d’Azil est bien connu pour
les grandes quantités d’ocre rouge qui
ont servi à décorer les fameux galets peints
du site, d’époque plus tardive. Il n’est
donc pas exclu que les petits bâtonnets en
os avec une extrémité pointue aient pu servir
à tatouer. Beaucoup d’autres outils et
aiguilles en os préhistoriques auraient pu
avoir cette fonction d’ailleurs, mais impossible
de le deviner quand il ne sont pas associés
à d’autres éléments d’un “kit” de tatouage.
Seize mille ans avant J.-C., c’est pas mal,
mais on peut encore trouver des indices plus
anciens de tatouage. Le matériel de la grotte
de Blombos en Afrique du Sud, qui date du
Paléolithique Moyen, pourrait aussi avoir
servi à tatouer. Les nombreuses pointes en
os provenant de niveaux datés d’il y a
entre 76 et 84 000 ans sont associées à
de grandes quantités d’ocre. Certaines
de ces pointes montrent même encore des traces
de pigment à leur extrémité polie par l’usage.
Traditionnellement, on pense qu’elles étaient
utilisées pour le traitement des peaux et
la confection de vêtements, mais l’hypothèse
du tatouage n’est pas à écarter. Si c’était
le cas, ce serait les plus anciens outils
de tatouage connus à ce jour.
On le voit, difficile d’avoir des certitudes
avec du matériel ou des images. On est obligés
de parler par hypothèse. Finalement, si on
veut pouvoir affirmer quelque chose, il faut
se baser sur de vrais restes de peau tatouée.
Or, vous le savez, les matières organiques
telles que le corps humain se décomposent
avec le temps. Pour que ce ne soit pas le
cas, il faut des conditions de préservation
exceptionnelles : du froid pour congeler,
du chaud et sec pour dessécher ou éventuellement
un milieu saturé en eau comme les tourbières.
C’est pourquoi les vestiges de peau tatouée
ne proviennent que de quelques régions du
globe. Il y en a quatre principales, auxquelles
il faut ajouter la trouvaille isolée d’Ötzi
dans les Alpes.
Je vous propose un rapide tour d’horizon
de ces momies tatouées avant qu’on se penche
sur un aspect vraiment inattendu de ces tatouages.
Au Pérou, on trouve de très bonnes conditions
de préservation pour les corps grâce au
climat désertique de la côte et aux traditions
funéraires qui consistaient à recouvrir
les morts de nombreuses couches de tissu.
C’est ce qui a permis de retrouver la plus
ancienne preuve de tatouage du monde, sur
une momie de la culture Chinchorro, datée
d’environ 6000 avant J.-C. Et le plus vieux
tatouage du monde est… une moustache. Nan
sérieusement, c’est un dessin de moustache
fait avec quelques points. C’est comme ça,
on juge pas…
Une autre momie, originaire de Chiribaya Alta
dans le sud du pays, vieille de 1000 ans,
a livré plusieurs tatouages qui ont été
analysés chimiquement. Cela a révélé que
des pigments différents avaient été utilisés
selon les parties du corps. Les tatouages
des mains, des motifs géométriques, étaient
réalisés avec de la suie reconnaissable
au microscope par des petites particules de
carbone régulières. Au contraire, les tatouages
circulaires situés sur le cou, étaient constitués
de restes de plantes carbonisées, formant
des particules irrégulières, plus grandes
et de composition chimique variée. C’est
assez bizarre, et on va garder ça à l’esprit
pour l’expliquer tout à l’heure.
Une autre momie, conservée au musée de Detmold
en Allemagne, a été étudiée récemment
avec de nouvelles techniques pour mieux comprendre
ses tatouages et a fait l’objet d’une
publication. Il s’agit d’une momie de
la culture Chiu-Chiu, du nord du Chili, tout
près de la frontière péruvienne et datée
d’environ 1300 après J.-C. C’est une
femme adulte, inhumée en position assise
et qui porte trois tatouages, un près de
la bouche et deux sur la poitrine. Ce sont
des cercles d’à peine 15 millimètres de
diamètre avec un point au centre. La fonction
de ces cercles, esthétique ou rituelle, nous
échappe largement.
Bien sûr, il y a des dizaines d’autres
momies tatouées au Pérou, malheureusement
toutes n’ont pas été étudiées en détail
et encore moins publiées. D’après les
restes humains, on peut toutefois estimer
qu’une partie significative de la population
du Pérou aux périodes anciennes devait porter
des tatouages, peut-être jusqu’à 30 % comme
certains archéologues l’ont suggéré.
La deuxième grande région qui livre des
restes de peau tatouée est l’Asie centrale,
à la fois grâce à des sols gelés, de l’air
sec du désert, mais aussi quelque chose de
plus inhabituel. Et c’est dans les steppes
du Sud de la Russie que ça se passe.
Dans deux kourganes, des sépultures sous
des tertres de pierre, datées de 2600 avant
J.-C., les tatouages ne sont pas sur des momies
mais sur des os. La peau ne s’est pas conservée
mais l’encre, composée de charbon et de
suie, s'est déposée sur les ossements pendant
la décomposition des corps. On possède donc
des traces sur le tibia et les métacarpes
d’une main, en fait sur des endroits où
la couche de peau est très fine et directement
au contact des os. Les motifs sont assez difficiles
à lire, mais c’est déjà assez extraordinaire
que le tatouage soit toujours visible alors
que la peau a disparu. L’un des motifs de
la jambe pourrait se rapprocher d’un serpent,
et c’est à mettre en relation avec le squelette
de serpent présent à côté du corps. Mais
on reparlera de cet exemple tout à l’heure.
Une momie du IIIe ou IVe siècle après J.-C.
originaire du site d’Oglakhty dans le sud
de la Sibérie et conservée à St-Petersbourg,
a elle, révélé de véritables tatouages
grâce à une étude en lumière infrarouge.
Le corps de cet homme était couvert de tatouages
sur le torse, les épaules, le dos et les
bras. La plupart des motifs sont assez énigmatiques,
mais on reconnaît tout de même un arc à
double courbure avec une flèche sur le bras
gauche.
Le cas le plus connu dans la région est sans
doute celui de l’homme de Pazyryk, une momie
datée du IIIe siècle avant J.-C. découverte
en 1948 dans l’Altaï sibérien et restée
congelée dans le permafrost, le sol toujours
gelé, protégé par la masse de pierre du
tombeau. Cet homme portait de magnifiques
tatouages zoomorphes sur les bras, des lions,
des chevaux, des béliers, des cervidés stylisés
et un grand poisson sur la jambe. L’homme
avait aussi une énigmatique série de petits
points tatoués le long de la colonne vertébrale.
Dans la même tombe, une femme portait des
tatouages également, et dans une tombe proche,
un homme présentait aussi de larges tatouages
dont un très grand félin. En plus des corps,
beaucoup de matières périssables ont été
conservées par le gel, dont du mobilier et
de la vaisselle en bois, des vêtements et
couvertures, des éléments de harnachement,
ceintures, coiffes, cordes, et même de fines
aiguilles qui pourraient avoir servi à tatouer.
Dans le Xinjiang (Sinchiang), à l’ouest
de la Chine, on connaît aussi des momies
tatouées, conservées par l’air sec du
désert du Taklamakan. L’une d’entre elles,
tatouée sur le visage et le dos de sa main
gauche, provient du site de Zaghunluq, et
date d’entre 1500 et 850 avant J.-C. Sur
le site de Qizilchoqa, plus au nord, d’autres
momies datées entre 800 et 550 avant J.-C.
présentent aussi des tatouages sur les mains,
les bras et le dos. Malheureusement toutes
les momies n’ont pas été étudiées en
détail ni publiées.
Bien sûr, la région emblématique des momies
reste l’Egypte. Les Egyptiens de l’Antiquité
avaient fait de la momification tout un art,
et élaboré des techniques complexes pour
conserver les corps du mieux possible. Pourtant
les momies tatouées d’Egypte sont pour
la plupart des momies naturelles, desséchées
par le climat désertique.
C’est le cas par exemple d’Amounet, une
prêtresse de la déesse Hathor, dont le nom
est connu grâce à la dédicace de son tombeau.
Ayant vécu vers 2000 avant J.-C., elle porte
de nombreux points tatoués sur le ventre
et le bas-ventre. Les momies dites des "danseuses"
de Deir el-Bahri, près de Thèbes et datées
de la même époque, présentent aussi des
tatouages de formes géométriques autour
des seins ou des hanches. Ce qui est intéressant,
c’est que ces motifs se retrouvent à l’identique
ou presque sur les statuettes de concubines
déposées comme offrandes funéraires aux
côtés des hommes. Les points disposés en
losange sont particulièrement reconnaissables.
Pareil, on garde ça en tête pour tout à
l’heure.
D’autres momies égyptiennes, provenant
de Gebelein, un peu plus au sud, et pourtant
exposées au British Museum depuis 1900, ont
livré récemment, plusieurs tatouages grâce
à une nouvelle analyse en lumière infrarouge.
Datées d’environ 3000 avant J.-C. ces momies
naturelles sont les plus anciennes traces
de tatouage en Egypte antique.
On sait aussi par un fragment de peau pris
en photo au début du XXe siècle, que le
tatouage existait plus au sud, en Nubie. Malheureusement,
ce fragment a été perdu, et on n'a pas trouvé
de documentation récente à ce sujet.
Dernière zone, l’Arctique. Grâce au froid
qui y règne toute l’année, les régions
polaires ont aussi conservé des momies. Au
Groenland, des momies de femmes montrent des
tatouages, qui forment en particulier une
ligne sur le visage. Réalisés à la manière
de points de suture, avec une aiguille et
du fil trempé dans le pigment, ils étaient
réalisés jusqu’au milieu du XXe siècle.
En Alaska, la momie d’un homme daté du
XVIIe siècle montre des lignes et des points
sur le poignet. D’après les pêcheurs locaux,
interrogés au moment de la découverte, c’était
une manière de comptabiliser les prises du
pêcheur. Celui-ci aurait inscrit dans sa
peau le nombre de baleines et de phoques capturés,
un peu comme les pilotes de guerre qui inscrivaient
des marques de victoires sur le fuselage de
leur avion pour compter les ennemis qu’ils
avaient abattus. Le tatouage, c’était un
peu le CV du pêcheur.
Enfin, on ne peut pas faire une archéologie
du tatouage sans évoquer rapidement Ötzi,
découvert en septembre 1991. Le célèbre
homme des glaces était congelé depuis 5300
ans à la frontière italo-autrichienne, à
3200 mètres d’altitude. Hormis son équipement,
arc, carquois, poignard en silex, hache en
cuivre et tout le nécessaire pour allumer
un feu, ses nombreux tatouages ont passionné
les archéologues.
Ce sont de petites lignes verticales groupées
notamment près de la colonne vertébrale,
et également deux petites croix, une à l’intérieur
du genou et l’autre près de la malléole.
La fonction de ces tatouages a beaucoup fait
débat, mais le fait qu’ils soient petits
et dans des zones peu visibles exclut manifestement
l’hypothèse de tatouages identitaires ou
marquant le statut social d’un individu.
C’est d’ailleurs le cas de plusieurs autres
tatouages qu’on a rencontrés dans notre
tour d’horizon. Il y en a des gros, bien
visibles et particulièrement travaillés,
ceux-là ils servent à marquer une appartenance
à un groupe, à montrer qu’on est quelqu’un
d’important, et il y en a d’autres, plus
discrets et bizarrement positionnés, comme
ceux d’Ötzi. C’est de ceux-là dont je
voudrais parler maintenant.
Les tatouages thérapeutiques
En fait, beaucoup des tatouages retrouvés
sur les momies peuvent être interprétés
comme des tatouages thérapeutiques, qui essayent
de guérir.
Pour Ötzi, le passage de son corps au scanner
a montré que les tatouages se concentrent
sur des endroits atteints par des pathologies.
Les tatouages situés sur la colonne vertébrale
correspondent par exemple à une altération
dégénérative des vertèbres lombaires,
bien identifiée par les médecins qui ont
étudié son squelette. Ceux du genou et de
la cheville sont à mettre en parallèle avec
l’usure prononcée de ces articulations,
qui devaient beaucoup le faire souffrir. En
fait, Ötzi s’est fait tatouer pour essayer
d’aller mieux.
En Asie centrale, on retrouve si vous vous
en souvenez bien, une ligne équivalente sur
le dos de l’homme de Pazyryk. Ces petits
points n’ont rien à voir avec les gros
tatouages d’animaux sur les bras, et il
y a fort à parier que ce monsieur souffrait
aussi des vertèbres lombaires. En ce qui
concerne le tatouage en forme de serpent conservé
sur le tibia, les archéologues ont découvert
qu’il avait en réalité été appliqué
directement sur une ancienne fracture, là
encore sans doute pour tenter de la guérir.
L’usage de venin de serpent est d’ailleurs
attesté ethnographiquement pour la guérison
de fracture en Sibérie et c’est un motif
classique des amulettes protectrices. Difficile
de dire si c’était déjà le cas il y a
plus de 4500 ans, mais cela peut nous faire
penser à un symbole magique de guérison.
Au Pérou, pour les tatouages sur la nuque
de la femme péruvienne qui avaient révélé
des restes de végétaux brûlés, là encore
c’est sans doute dans un but thérapeutique.
Les archéologues rapprochent ces traces d’une
pratique de moxibustion, un mélange d’acupuncture
et de brûlure thérapeutique connue chez
de nombreux peuples au Tibet, au Japon, en
Sibérie, en Inde, en Irak, en Égypte ou au
Maghreb. Cela consiste à faire brûler des
herbes médicinales directement sur la peau,
ou même à l’intérieur d’une incision
avant d’appliquer un pansement. La cicatrisation
piège alors les parties carbonisées des
plantes et forme un tatouage. Dans le cas
de la momie de Chiribaya, ces traces circulaires
se recouvrent partiellement et sont distribuées
de manière asymétrique, ce qui renforce
l’idée d’un traitement localisé et répété
de douleurs cervicales. Ce n’est peut-être
que la partie visible d’un processus médical
plus complexe, qui a pu intégrer l’ingestion
de plantes, la médiation d’esprits et plein
d’autres choses qu’on ne saura jamais.
En Égypte, les symboles tatoués sur les femmes
auraient pu aussi fonctionner comme des amulettes
permanentes pour prévenir les difficultés
des grossesses et des accouchements. C’est
en tout cas ce que pense l’égyptologue
britannique Joann Fletcher qui a étudié
la distribution de ces tatouages, sur le ventre,
la poitrine ou en haut des cuisses. Ces motifs
de losanges ponctués s’étiraient avec
le corps de la femme enceinte et formaient
une sorte de filet protecteur autour du corps.
Certaines fois, ce sont même des images du
dieu Bes, le protecteur des femmes enceintes,
qui devaient être tatouées en haut des cuisses,
c’est en tout cas ce que suggère l’iconographie
à partir d’un bol en faïence décoré.
Enfin, en Arctique, d’après les Inuit interrogés,
les tatouages servaient à prévenir les douleurs
de l’accouchement ou à éviter la stérilité.
Les tatouages thérapeutiques sont par ailleurs
connus chez de nombreux peuples comme les
Yupiks, qui vivent en Tchoukotka, au bord
du détroit de Béring et en Alaska. Cela
peut prendre notamment la forme de gardiens
tatoués sur le visage ou de symboles géométriques,
aux vertus protectrices.
On le voit, les tatouages anciens pouvaient
avoir une fonction thérapeutique. La pratique
du tatouage a eu depuis la Préhistoire un
rôle de marqueur social important, utilisée
par exemple lors de rites de passage à l’âge
adulte ou pour souligner l’appartenance
à une élite, mais le fait de marquer la
peau a aussi été depuis des millénaires,
un acte médical.
Pour traiter un rhumatisme, soigner une inflammation,
stimuler la production de lait des jeunes
mères, guérir une fracture, faire disparaître
des migraines ou n’importe quelle autre
douleur, le tatouage a été employé dans
le monde entier. Il est vrai que la suie ou
le charbon peuvent avoir des propriétés
antiseptiques donc par association d'idées,
pourquoi ne pas les mettre directement dans
la peau ? La trace tatouée donne à voir,
dans la durée, qu’un acte de guérison
a été pratiqué. Impuissantes face à de
nombreuses douleurs mystérieuses, bon nombre
de sociétés ont donc eu recours à ces placebos
qui s’exhibent et qu’ils pensaient avoir
de réels pouvoirs de guérison et de protection.
Et c’était le cas dans plusieurs régions
du monde, comme Bornéo ou les Philippines
jusqu’à y’a pas si longtemps.
Donc, si vous aimez les tatouages, et que
vous voulez aider à résorber la dette de
la Sécurité Sociale, j’ai une proposition
: faites vous tatouer directement une molécule
de paracétamol, c’est petit, c’est joli,
et peut-être que ça marche…
Dîtes-le moi dans les commentaires.